sorts first of all on the strike action
well nobody wants strikes and I've
spoken to ambulance Cruz and they don't
want to go on strikes what I think the
concern is is that the government hasn't
been listening and the figures that
we've published today as a result of
lots of freedom information requests
because the government didn't want you
to know show that the delays on
ambulances are the worst ever and what
they show is that people with serious
life-threatening conditions with
potential strokes and heart attacks the
ambulances aren't arriving on time and
even when they do pick up the patient
they're having to wait for sometimes
hours to get a bed in a in a hospital
and I just think of those patients there
sometimes they've been in in serious
pain their families will deeply worried
and the ambulance service under the
conservatives is failing at the worst
records ever
um and let's be clear these figures that
little Democrats have attained the
government didn't want you to know
they only publish the figures at a
regional level not the local level we've
gone down to 227 local areas to find
which communities many of them your
viewers will be living in where the
ambulance service just aren't hitting
the targets not just delaying uh getting
to people and that's that's a real real
crisis for NHS and it comes on top of
all the other crises we we know so this
Paints the picture for me of a
government that just hasn't got a grip
and either they're completely out of
touch which is quite likely they're
certainly taking people uh for granted
and this chaos has to end
um and so liberal Democrats are calling
for an action plan to sort out this to
get the staff we need to sort out
um the resources we need for new
ambulance stations and so on and then we
could get a grip of this
yeah just just to clarify you're
supporting the strikes or not
but listen no one wants people to go on
strike of course they don't we want to
make sure that people don't have to go
on strikes and what's really surprising
is I think the government should be
talking to the unions to solve this
ahead of Christmas they shouldn't be
allowing uh there to be this this is
emptiness and you know ministers aren't
even going on on the radio and the TV
today to explain themselves even though
these are the worst figures ever for
ambulance delays where is the government
we've been warning the government about
this for well over a year okay give you
an example okay I I was knocking on
doors uh a year ago in the north
Shropshire by-election and in the rural
communities of North Shropshire we found
that the biggest issue that people were
raising with us was ambulance delays our
excellent new liberal Democrat MP had a
Morgan for North Shropshire has been
raising this ever since she got elected
after that violation she's asked for
meetings she's asked for investigations
she's been pushing this as hard as she
can supported by our health spokesperson
Daisy Cooper and they've been saying
they've talked to patients they've
talked to ambulance Crews why isn't the
government doing that why is the
government failing on this so badly and
we'd be refusing to be held to account
and the reason we looked at this
research and got all this new figures
out there was to reveal those areas
where it's uh seriously uh affecting
lives and putting lives in danger and
there are some communities particularly
some rural communities where I really
worry that people are dying because the
government haven't sorted out the
ambulance service but what about Sir Ed
if people die as a result of the strike
action that's why I'm pressing you if I
may on whether you support it or not
what I do want to see is that the
emergency cover that the ambulance crews
are saying they will provide to make
sure that really happens in supported by
managers and the government uh no one
wants to see the strikes we want to make
sure that the emergency cover remains
there that's what they say is going to
happen it's crucial that it does
um but I want the government to make
sure the strikes don't happen in the
first place and the way to do that is
for government to show that they are
listening for once they've refused to
listen
um for so long they've been warned about
this they've been hiding away from the
figures they're Sliding Away from
scrutiny they have got to step in now
they're the government
and they could stop these strikes if
they chose
now I understand that but with respect
you are you are not answering my
question and my question is do you
support strike action that puts patients
lives at risk it's a yes or no question
okay okay with respect I've said nobody
wants to see strikes I've said that
three times
um and uh that's that so you don't
support the strike action then you don't
support strikes rights don't ultimately
help but the point is that government
um is the other party to this
and the government shouldn't avoid the
responsibility it wants to do that he
wants to try to blame everyone else when
actually it's the government to blame
and when I've talked to ambulance Crews
they are really worried about their
patients
that they do this job it's a hard job
it's a tough job it's not really very
well paid but they do it because they
want to serve their Community they want
to make sure people who are potentially
would die if they don't get a hospital
get to hospital they want to make sure
people who need help need pain relief
get that pain relief and then they get
to a doctor that's what they do they
give their lives for that and they have
been suffering themselves and they are
extremely cross that the government
doesn't look at the evidence doesn't
look at the facts and doesn't work on
behalf of of millions of people out
there who rely on these Services isn't
it a scandal cake
that in 2022 in the United Kingdom when
you call 999 you can't be sure if the
ambulance will turn up in a reasonable
time
the postcode Lottery that people face in
some areas our country they can't rely
on the ambulance turning up and
ultimately the government are
responsible for that and they they can't
hide behind the idea that this is
suddenly news they've known about this
we've warned about this uh and I think
it's one of the biggest scandals in the
NHS and let's remember that other parts
of the NHS that are failing miserably
too you know we've called for extra
resources for GP appointments so that
people can get earlier GP appointments
we've said that we need greater access
to NHS dentists we've pointed out that
the promise that the government made to
build 40 hospitals I think voice Johnson
used to talk about 40 hospitals that
promise hasn't been delivered on
um and it pains me to say this but I
think I've never known the NHS in in
such a crisis in our lifetime and I just
don't think the government have got a
grips with this and it's putting
people's lives in jeopardy